a movie that my subscribers do not give
a about awesome if I can't make
this review funny I'll try to at least
make it interesting mr. Popper's
Penguins now mr. Popper's Penguins is
about mr. popper who gets penguins yeah
it's all in the title like literally and
mr. popper is played by the Jim Carrey
remember when a new Jim Carrey movie was
like a new Metallica album or like
Linkin Park you're like I gotta check it
out like right now and now it's you know
like mr. Popper's Penguins so in this
movie mr. popper Jim Carrey is like
estranged from his family they don't
care about him his kids don't want to
stay with them and he gets these
penguins and then they're all interested
and they're all family again and it's
all awesome for him but you you're like
Carrie what happened it's like he's
doing rated PG family movies now to make
up for the rawness and me myself and
Irene trying to create balance in the
world carla Gugino is in it she plays
Jim Carrey's ex-wife which they're
pretty cool for being exes I've seen
divorced couples they don't act like
this Jim Carrey and this girl are like
BFFs so the whole so in the family back
together thing it was really nice to see
I'm here to crack some realism into some
skulls I'm seen as a realist that is
but to this movies credit it's
not horrible if you're like 10 I mean
kids will love this movie it has a
bonding family element to it I get all
that stuff but if I saw one more penguin
in this movie I swear to god I was
sick of seeing penguin I literally
started gagging I was like that happened
and Angela Lansbury's in this movie and
something tells me about 3/4 of you just
now were like what the hell is an Angela
Lansbury
you know mrs. Potts from beating the
Beast Murder She Wrote I'm gonna level
with you I don't know anything else that
she's done but you know she plays an old
chick she doesn't really well though as
for how I liked the movie I saw why it
will appeal to families and it does that
well and Jim Carrey steals this movie
it's not really hard to do but 9 out of
10 things this movie has going for it is
all because of Jim Carrey I peed in the
movie not like in the movie but usually
when I sucked down about 84 gallons of
$600 concession soda I'm like all right
magneto just shoot your rockets at the
boat in this movie I was like oh look at
that gotta piss I'll be back it's funny
Jim Carrey did like the iconic comedies
of the 90s then he started doing dramas
and now he doesn't really do either I
was holding onto that one on the right
home I was driving home in my car and I
was like I'm totally gonna use that
that is awesome chicks dig my ride you
know I'm Mario Kart and I speak for all
the fathers who are gonna get dragged to
this movie this Sunday god bless you all
I would say it's a good time if you're
drunk yeah you deadbeat dad getting
drunk taking your kid to a movie shame
on you although I did just tell you to
do that so that's weird however your
favorite Jim Carrey movie comedy-drama
doesn't matter what is it comment below
let me know if you like I need to review
one to kind of create balance in my own
little way but if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more of
this system never changes click right
here to see more
[Music]